hey guys welcome back to our weekly dead
stirring recap now there wasn't a ton of
news but there was a pretty there was a
good enough amount for me to make a
video most of the stuff in the dev
stream was just the devs facing other
players but the new characters kind of
showing off their moves so if you don't
have the season pass or don't know how
to play any of the characters you can go
into the dead stream go into the twitch
vaad or on youtube they do have it
posted on the whole YouTube channel and
you can go to that section and kind of
watch some of the bites and see what a
centering or shinobi should be playing
like but there was some other
information I do want to share a few so
let's get right into that so the first
thing on the list is if you are missing
your rewards for season one please
contact do be self support and they will
probably get your items to you by today
or hopefully by the end of the week
hopefully now you kind of support group
isn't exactly the greatest but the
desserted say they are definitely
working on getting the season pass stuff
for other players so like I said if you
are missing it please contact their
support groups you can get your rewards
román one of the devs on the Warriors
den stream is now the creative director
so very big congrats to Roman this is
just a personal thing I wanted to share
with any of you if you did care but the
next bit of information is the community
ask some questions during the stream one
of them had to do with spawn wedging if
you don't know what spawn legend is
basically whenever you respawn there's
that three to four second animation of
the character kind of zoom or the camera
zooming in on your character well within
that time this one warlord player would
grab you and led you off the map before
you could even move causing you to
basically be defenseless and caught in
the loop if you're kind of confused I'll
put the video up in a couple I'll show a
quick short clip of it so that you can
understand what happens while I'm
explaining this but basically it doesn't
really look that great and thankfully
I've never actually had to run into this
and any of my matches because honestly
I'd be furious if this happened to me I
want to hear your comments on this the
next question I have is about the
defensive mother and the devs dead-stick
they're making changes to them to the
defensive meta but there is no confirmed
release date but they're going to be
focusing on more buffing the samurai
characters specifically Orochi Nobu she
and Ken say sono should go he or she
know we just yet
so also cancer is finally getting some
love for once because to be honest that
most recent Buffy had didn't really help
too much but once these buffs are taken
care of they're going to be focusing on
the defensive meta and only that for the
next couple weeks so we can hopefully
not have to deal with multiple Turtles
such as warlord also when they balance
these characters like I mentioned from
shinobi and shinobi no blue she Orochi
and kent say they look at the top seven
best players for each character to get
the accurate stats which i believe is
the correct way to do it because if you
have a player who's never played the
character starts bitching and moaning
about how all this character isn't this
so they need a buff but also kind of
ruins the stats a bunch of new players
could be using Centurion and he could
have a [ __ ] KD ratio or [ __ ] matchup one
rate compared to other characters and
then they bought them when they don't
need to buff him so luckily the only
taking the top 7% of players which I
which I did like I did stay is a very
good idea speaking of characters they're
also looking at Shinobi's kick they
haven't really stated what they're going
to do but I kind of I'm kind of assuming
that it might be too fast for people to
react to but the devs are going to be
waiting about two to three weeks to even
think about buffing or northing the new
characters because they don't want to
buffering her from too early and cause
them to be broken so there's going to be
a couple weeks until this kick is looked
at in my opinion though I don't really
believe that the kick is too hard to
dodge as soon as he goes into the smoke
you just kind of have the dodge roll out
of there so it's really not that hard to
be it's really not hard to take care of
that
but speaking of dodge roll the devs are
also looking at testing dodge roll by
either making it vulnerable to attacks
like boarding shoulder bash or guard
breaks or completely taking out of the
game entirely I don't know exactly why
they decided to come up with this but do
the devs so they must have some
reasoning for it also the outfits I
talked about a couple videos ago which
were the vertigo splatter an optical
illusion are now in the game so if you
do have that extra steel go buy those
outfits if you do please and then the
next coming weeks as well players will
hopefully be able to ramp up revamped
all the controls instead of using the
presets the game gives us and lastly for
the bit of information of the dev stream
this
Barr's for the gear is now being
combined soon so now we will see a
percentage and progression bar this is
entirely great news because those
percentage sets are so confusing in an
absolute eyesore to me so like I did
state there's going to do the
percentages for the people that do
understand it and then the progression
bar for people that like me don't like
the percentages too much anyway that's
going to be the end of the video today
guys I hope you all did enjoy and if you
do want to see yesterday's video where
we talked about some new leaf executions
emotes and effects coming soon which do
look amazing and you don't want to miss
out
then click the card at the top to watch
that and if you did like this video hit
the like button if you're new to this
channel hit the subscribe button and
turn on notifications so you never miss
one of my videos and you get to become
part of the notification squad anyway
guys goodbye and I'll see you in the
next video